like I said I'm going to show you three
ways to do this this is the first way
which was a a pure a purely graphical
method okay well as pure as we can get
if you don't like this method you must
still master it okay
later on like these other messes are
going to show you they sort of run in
parallel you can choose them if you if
you feel it's easier in that particular
question okay but two things number one
sometimes in the HSC they'll actually
prescribe a method they'll have to go
say he's a question right he's pas de
Graaff it and then they'll say Papi's
hints hints now if you're lucky they'll
say hints or otherwise which means you
can do whichever way you like right but
in a non-trivial number of questions
particularly in the end they'll say
hints and you must you like they're
trying to assess your ability to use a
particular technique okay
so that's the first thing secondly you
will encounter problems like because
you're smeet such a wide range of them
okay that one technique will be clearly
better than another okay and if you've
mentally sort of decided for yourself
I'm not going to use this technique ever
I'm just gonna use the other ones
because I prefer them then you're kind
of limited to like you know some things
are better dude you're right here
there's some things that go through your
left hand you're like I'm never gonna
use my left hand but if this ever
something where it actually you should
use your left hand you're kind of like
stuck going like doing something awkward
and you're just gonna be like you know
when you come up with silly errors it's
because you choose an ineffective method
okay
number one was a graphical solution okay
we are going to still use graphs just
because there's such a good way to
visualize what's going on but there's
another way to approach this okay number
two and this is kind of okay the first
thing we do is instead of just working
with this as it is we're going to gather
everything algebraically on one side of
the inequality right we're going to
gather on one side and then we're going
to take the second step the second step
will be different for the third
I show you this time we're going to
multiply by the square I've showed you
this before but let's have a look at it
as to how applies to this specific
question let's give this a go
there's the Equality I'm beginning with
I'll take everything everyone to one
side so I get 3 over X plus 2 minus X
less than or equal to 0 ok now this on
its own looks like what have you done to
the question look very much ok I'm going
to do one more step and I'm actually
going to profoundly improve the odds of
what we're looking at doesn't look like
a very profound step doesn't look right
for a found ok but it's actually very
useful and it's a strategy you can use
over and over again
ok the reason why this is kind of
finicky okay is because you're trying to
work with these values that are up in
the difficult spots okay but when you're
solving this this problem I can bring
down to just finding roots if you're
very good at right if I can find roots I
can find where something crosses the
axis and that's what this means where
something positive it just means above
the axis I think we're really good at
finding it so in order to make it just a
little bit easier to work with we're
gonna multiply by the square and when I
say the square I mean X plus 2 or
squared why do I have to multiply by the
square again so that I ensure that what
a x is positive so I don't have to muck
around with the direction of the
inequality
okay so let's go ahead and do that
yeah I should have said up thank you all
right good now what have I got here I've
multiplied through by the square okay so
I've multiplied this by X plus 2 squared
I multiplied this by X plus 2 all
squared one of the X plus 2's cancels
because I've got one of the denominators
that's why I only have one here okay now
it's great that we got mentioned here
that we have to mention this inequality
because these two things right they're
not the same they're not the same right
that first slide has hyperbolas in it
with discontinuities okay what's this
thing you can attack you bit without
expanding you can already see it's a
cubed and cubics don't have Breton
cubics are continuous things as you're
about to see so that's why it's really
important that we mentioned this because
if you don't these are different
questions now what do we do in this
thing if you're like me your first
instinct is to expand and that's a
terrible instinct why cause it's already
factorized for you right so you might as
well retain that factor through it
expand that right because then you turn
it into ergo a ton factorize cubic which
is a mess okay and you're gonna have to
take that X plus 2 out anyway because we
want to know what this thing looks like
and a factorized form will be
tremendously useful for us so take out X
plus 2 what are you left with
okay well I'm gonna do a big free pair
of property but I take one of them out
of here I'm left doing X X plus 2 and
then here that's gone so I just have a
negative 3 so far so good
ok now it's time to expand all right
when you have a look at this thing X
plus 2 and then I've got x squared plus
2x minus 3 that should look kind of
familiar
where did we just see this ha ha is that
a coincidence no coincidence
all right so being that I've already
factorize the thing I know if this thing
looks like I've got X plus 2 X plus 3 X
minus 1
when's that greater than or equal to 0
now because cubics are so much simpler
kinds of ideas I'm living well
personally I'm going to get away with a
somewhat smaller graph if you've already
drawn your axes that's okay but here's
what's going to look like I have three
ribs three intercepts for the x-axis
where are they
there's three negative two one okay keep
in mind we said I'm not actually equal
to negative two right so it's kind of an
intercept but not right so let me draw
it negative three let's put some scale
that'll be a bill this is negative three
there's negative two and is one okay so
I want my cubit to pass through these
three points okay what's it going to
look like very very roughly yeah that's
right it's going to be skyrocketing
upwards for positive infinity and
spiraling downwards to the negative
infinity because of the leading
coefficient here which is just one it's
positive so this is what I thought okay
now it's worth mentioning very quickly
but the scale of this thing is wildly
inaccurate right I know because I've
actually graphed it this this thing here
this this dip is kind of vertex thing
which is called a stationary point this
station point should be way lower it's
very much okay but but well yeah my
graph is wrong but you know what because
of how I phrase the question doesn't
matter I don't care about scale down
here really because what I'm trying to
work out is when is this graph above or
equal to the axis okay so again
get out your new color right have a look
at the parts were interested in I'm
gonna go from this part over yeah
right that part works it's above the
axis and here's another part that's
above the axis
okay now just like before I note for
different reasons I have a I have a
restriction here domain restriction so
even though negative two it actually
looks like it's within my region it's
not right because I expressly excluded
it from the beginning this parts okay
this parts okay and surprise surprise I
have exactly the same answer that I had
before right negative 3 inclusive up to
negative 2 not inclusive and then from 1
onwards okay so if you are the kind of
person who hooks and magical functions
and feels sick then one of the
approaches you can take is to transform
this thing right x Square and make it a
cubic problem okay so that's one way to
go about this